Восьмий місяць оборони Бахмута.
Місто, де уже сьомий місяць поспіль триває найбільш кровопролитна битва російсько-української війни.
У місті не стихає канонада артилерії, мінометів, стрілецької зброї.
Бахмут оточений з трьох боків. Росіяни намагаються стиснути лещата й перерізати останні шляхи постачання ЗСУ.
Утім українські військові продовжують тримати місто.
Вітання з українського Бахмута! Фортеця тримається!
Юрій Сиротюк - один з оборонців Бахмута, солдат-гранатометник 5-ої окремої штурмової бригади.
Його підрозділ перебуває на півдні міста, де росіяни, зокрема ПВК "Вагнер",
намагаються перерізати трасу Костянтинівка-Бахмут - одну з останніх артерій для міста.
Нею доставляють усе: воду, їжу, боєприпаси. Нею ж підвозять і вивозять людей.
Очевидно, що дуже важка зараз оборона.
Не можна сказати, що це все дуже просто  і нам це все легко вдається.
Обстріл з трьох боків, артилерія постійно працює над головою,
рухатися по відкритій місцевості практично неможливо, тому що росіяни стріляють хаотично.
За словами ветерана АТО Євгена Дикого, у армії РФ закінчуються снаряди.
Тож росіяни більше не можуть активно застосовувати тактику вогняного валу:
руйнувати будівлі артилерією і не залишати ЗСУ позицій для оборони.
Натомість, кидають у бій якомога більше людей.
За даними українського міноборони, росіяни щодня втрачають 500 людей убитими.
Це так звана "руска трьохволновка" або "трьохслойка".  Це коли просто женуть гарматне м'ясо.
Коли одна хвиля просто завідомо лягає, тобто їх фактично списують ще до початку бою.
Друга хвиля завідомо лягає, а тільки вже третя заходить на позиції оборонців,
тому що оборонці за цей час втомились, боєкомплект закінчується,
та навіть банально стволи перегріваються.
Коли ми говоримо, що захисників Бахмута засипають з трупами,
то в даному разі це не літературний образ. Це прямий опис ландшафта.
Президент Володимир Зеленський запевняє, що ЗСУ контролюють усі ділянки фронту.
Водночас в Офісі президента не виключають, що українські військові можуть відступити від Бахмута на більш вигідні позиції.
Такий варіант розглядає й військовий експерт Ґустав Ґрессель.
Проблема полягає в тому, що хоча все ще є дороги, що ведуть до Бахмута,
які не підпадають під прямий вогонь російських військ,
ми перебуваємо на відстані одного російського прориву від такої ситуації.
Якщо росіяни це зроблять, то українські сили в Бахмуті, а також цивільні особи,
які ще залишаються в місті, опиняться в пастці.
Потрібно вжити запобіжних заходів, щоб усунути таку можливість:
або заздалегідь евакуювати гарнізон з Бахмута, або здійснити контратаку,
щоб відтіснити російські війська. Утім, таку контратаку треба було б починати зараз.
Інакше ситуація буде дуже критичною.
Поки офіційного рішення про відвід українських військ із Бахмута немає.
Деякі експерти вважають, що воно вже може бути ухваленим,
утім про такий крок не повідомлятимуть, аби не давати переваги противнику.
На думку Євгена Дикого, у ЗСУ ще є шанси прорватися на півдні.
Якби вдалося відкинути ворога за Кліщіївку, шляхи постачання до міста можна було б захистити й далі тримати оборону.
Водночас рішення відійти від Бахмута, за словами військового, було б не трагічним, але складним.
Тому що тоді із прифронтових одразу стають фронтовими,
тобто такими, як зараз Бахмут, одразу три великі міста.
Це Костянтинівка, це Краматорськ, це Славянськ.
З військової точки зору тримати оцю міську агломерацію Славянськ-Краматорськ можна роками.
Навіть Пригожин оцінює, що він би штурмував цю агломерацію півтора року.
Ну, а хто ж йому півтора року дасть?
Тобто з військової точки зору це не прорив фронту, це не обвал фронту,
це навіть не вихід на кордони Донецької області. Зовсім ні.
Але з гуманітарної точки зору це доведеться вивозити населення з трьох великих міст, кожне з яких більше за Бахмут.
І, знову ж таки, оця нова лінія фронту по цих трьох містах буде довшою, ніж нинішня лінія фронту по Бахмуту,
себто вона потребуватиме більшої кількості людей.
На думку Ґустава Ґресселя, для ЗСУ важливо берегти сили для майбутнього контрнаступу,
тож відхід на більш вигідні позиції був би непоганим кроком.
Українські війська вже підготували нову лінію оборони в глибині.
Вони відійдуть до неї. Звісно, віддавати будь-яке місто боляче,
тому що його треба буде знову відвоювати в певний момент часу.
Але у військовому плані нічого не зміниться. Росіяни просунуться на кілька кілометрів і все.
На захід від Бахмута є хороші позиції, які можна обороняти.
Натомість журналіст Юрій Бутусов, який не раз бував на позиціях ЗСУ у Бахмуті
й регулярно спілкується з військовими, вважає, що до нинішньої критичної ситуації в місті
призвели системні помилки командування в комплектуванні й застосуванні військ.
А втрата міста може призвести до стратегічного погіршення позицій ЗСУ на Донбасі.
Бахмут, звичайно, не варто було звідти відходити, оскільки конфігурація фронту в районі Соледар-Бахмут,
рельєф, був абсолютно на нашу користь.
Це були в усіх сенсах дуже зручні позиції.
Там був зручний рельєф, висоти, наш бік, вигідні комунікації,
велика щільність забудови, яка дозволяла розташовувати значну кількість військ.
Тобто, в принципі, все це було на нашу користь.
І те, що ми не змогли реалізувати, треба чесно собі визнати, що це проблема не кількості заліза.
Ніколи не може бути стільки боєпропасів на війні, як нам треба.
Колись 70-тисячне місто Бахмут не вважалося стратегічно важливим.
Але після семи місяців запеклих боїв стало символічним для обох сторін.
Місто є стратегічно важливим, попри те, що в ЗМІ часто говорили про протилежне.
По-перше, для росіян взяття Бахмута стане важливим для підняття бойового духу.
Тоді як для українських військових це буде психологічно складно.
До того ж, втрата Бахмута може підірвати віру західних партнерів у спроможності української армії.
Велика військова цінність захисту Бахмута полягала в тому,
що росіянам важко взяти місто, оскільки вони втрачають багато своїх переваг у вогневій потужності,
вступаючи в дуже близький бій з українськими військами.
Але, як ми бачили також у Лисичанську, а тепер і в Бахмуті,
вони намагаються уникнути боїв у місті,
а натомість просуваються на околиці міста на відкритій місцевості,
на північ і південь від нього і загрожують місту, намагаючись його оточити.
Проблема полягає в тому, що не так багато російських сил стягуються в місто
і вступають у прямі міські бої, що завжди є перевагою для українців.
Юрій Сиротюк, який захищає одну з критично важливих доріг для міста, вважає тривалу оборону Бахмута недаремною.
Військовий каже, що його підрозділ готовий тримати місто, поки є такий наказ від командування.
Вони мріяли до послання Путіна біля літачка сфотографуватися
цього знаменитого бахмутського - не вдалося. Потім до 24-го не вдалося.
Потім Путін ставив завдання до кінця лютого звільнити Бахмут.
Найголовніше те, що ми виснажимо їхню армію.
Тому що якби ми не стримали тут у Бахмуті ворога, то Путін напевно сьогодні проводив би якісь стратегічні наступи.
Невідомо чи на Київ, чи на Харків, чи на Запоріжжя, але точно він кудись рухався б.
А так він застряг під Бахмутом і замість того, щоб вилізти з цієї пастки,
яка фактично для нього є пасткою, вони отак лобом б'ються об двері Бахмута,
щоб довести, що вони це місто можуть взяти.
Тим часом у практично зруйнованому Бахмуті досі залишаються близько чотирьох тисяч цивільних.
Серед них майже півсотні дітей. Це дані Донецької ОВА.
Поки ще житло ціле…
Поки сам цілий, поки ще залишуся.
А цей польовий госпіталь - нагадування про ціну, яку Україна платить за кожен сантиметр своєї землі.
Тут надають допомогу пораненим, яких щойно евакуювали з Бахмута.
Мої медики працюють практично цілодобово.
Якщо не при повномасштабному вторгненні за вісім-дев'ять місяців ротації
в мене було десь 50-60 "трьохсотих" за дев'ять місяців,
то в нас зараз за добу буває більше, тому дуже-дуже багато роботи, але вони в мене кращі.
Вони рятують наших бійців, забирають з того світу.
У нас група з семи осіб.
Стало шість.
Тепер мінус я.
Тобто п'ять.
Четверо контужені.
Група "Альфа" вистояла.
Він моргає мені.